- I don't feel like I deserve nice crisps.
- Yeah.
- They're possibly slightly glittery.
- Is there stars on them?
- Oh my god there's stars!
- That's mad.
- Wow, they taste a bit like a bath bomb.
- That's just all sugar isn't it?
- They're like fizzing on my
tongue, put it on your tongue.
- Maybe like a nice fizz, like Skips.
- Prosecco and gammon.
- Maybe a bellini?
- Champagne crisps or some shit.
I bet someone's put like
fucking berries in it.
- Yay!
Although winter berries, what
the hell is a winter berry?
- It actually has dried prosecco wine in.
- It's pretty sweet, it's
a bit like a dessert crisp.
- I would like to replace
after eight mints with these.
- It smells like an old pub.
- Facon.
- OK so we gotta go beef, sage, and gravy.
- [Lady on right] It's fishy.
- Maybe it's like a seafood.
Seafood and lemon.
- Oh--
- Scampi.
- Yep.
- (laughs)
- Not really meat.
- We were wrong on everything.
- What?
- That's posh as fuck.
- Ya, ya, ya.
- Logically these should be
closer to like prawn cocktail
and these are not prawn cocktail.
These are good.
They've got like a little bit of
what looks like dirt on them.
- Smoky lemon flavour? (laughs)
- Smoked lemons.
- They're mint and lamb.
- I think this is like a
fancy roast chicken one.
- It smells a bit like the
lamb cat food my cats eat.
- [Lady on right] Yes.
- Yay!
- Admit that it's just
basically fancy kebab though.
- I mean if these were in a
large glass bowl at a party
I'd be pretty impressed.
- But it's not just any
lamb, it's salt marsh lamb.
- I'm quite in to baby sheep now.
- It looks like potpourri.
- Parsnip crisps.
- Possibly cassava?
- I don't know what that is.
- [Man on left] Or plantain?
- How could you eat that?
- You couldn't eat that
with any sort of dignity.
- It smells quite like perfume-y.
- They're mad sweet,
that's like the sweetest
thing I've ever had.
- It tastes like burnt caramel.
- Bacon glazed parsnip.
- Dill and honey parsnips with
truffle oil, I don't know!
Maple and pancetta parsnip crisps.
- Literally no pancetta in that.
- If bacon is pancetta
and honey was maple,
we've got this spot on.
- Do you know what we've done?
- We've done a kind of
like keeping it real
English version of this.
- This is a smoky bacon
crisp done horribly wrong.
- Whoever was supposed
to put in the pancetta
has just fucked it off,
they've gone found a pub.
- It's opened my eyes to
the bourgeois crisp world.
- Ya.
- Posh scampi or the
posh roast I quite like.
- Instead of handing around the gold balls
and the Ferrero Rocher,
they hand round some prosecco crisps.
- Hi.
- Hello.
- Hey guys!
- [All] Sarah!
- Up here.
- We made a series.
- It's coming on November 18th.
- Please watch it.
- Get it here. Over here.
- There, over there.
- You got it.
- I think they got it, OK.
- I'm out.
- OK bye
- It will be released 2015, November, OK.